mes grands parents étaient de la
dernière génération monolingue donc mes
grands-parents ne parlait pas l'anglais
et il y avait une espèce de d'entente un
accommodement raisonnable donc mes
parents sont allés à l'école il n'avait
jamais entendu un mot d'anglais
et puis c'est obligé de parler anglais
points tout ce qui fait que la
génération de mes parents quand ils ont
commencé à élever leurs enfants ont
arrêté deux de leur parler dans leur
langue maternelle et on a commencé à
parler aux enfants si l'adema génération
en anglais avec eux à la maison on
parlait l'anglais avec mes parents mais
dès qu'il y avait un vieux qui n'était
qu' qui était monolingue francophone on
parle de france et par respect et moi
j'étais toujours fasciné par ces gens là
parce qu'il me semblait qu'ils avaient
tellement plus de plaisir la génération
de mes grands parents c'était vraiment
pour moi un espèce de génération meetic
il se tait il y avait un joie de vivre
qui était vraiment incroyable
mon engagement envers la francophonie je
crois est due à la recherche de cette ce
sentiment de cette sensation de bonheur
que je trouvais dans le salon chez andré
boudreau parce que tout le monde crier
tout le monde s'amusait il y avait ma
grand-mère qui mettait son mouchoir par
terre puis danser sur les quatre coins
seul dans le pays qui pourrait le faire
donc il y avait cette espèce
d'exubérance et une façon de passer à
travers la vie qui était totalement
ailleurs que cette notion très sérieuse
de la réussite américaine et puis
travailler puis tout ça qui était
vraiment l'héritage pense
de mon expérience allons dire américaine
tout ça pour dire qu'il y avait quand
même quelque part dans mon expérience de
jeune garçon
cette zone où on parlait français et
puis on s'amusait mais beaucoup avant
tout se passait là dedans de la façon la
plus la plus joyeuse et je sais il ya ma
façon de de retrouver cette expérience